[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le magazine des temps
forts à l'assemblée et au sénat avec à
mes côtés en rien de mancini
bonjour katia et cette semaine notre
invité est hervé marseille bonjour vous
êtes sénateur des hauts-de-seine vous
êtes le président du groupe union
centriste au sénat
merci d'être avec nous avec d'abord les
services publics français peu touché par
la radicalisation de leur personnel
c'est le diagnostic d'un rapport
parlementaire mais leurs auteurs
appellent à la vigilance pour mieux
détecter le phénomène notamment dans les
prisons la santé ou encore les
transports
nouvel avertissement de la cour des
comptes sur les finances publiques le
rapport annuel était publié cette
semaine et didier migaud premier
président de la cour des comptes était
auditionné devant le sénat les députés
examinent le projet loi climat énergie
objectifs à atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 parmi les points chauds
du texte les passoires thermiques le
gouvernement a présenté son dispositif
pour lutter contre ces logements mal
isolés et puis le parlement joue les
prolongations à partir de lundi débute
la session extraordinaire avec un agenda
chargé
au menu notamment le texte sur notre
dame où la fin du parcours parlementaire
de la réforme de la fonction publique
les services publics face à la
radicalisation de leur personnel c'est
la question à la une cette semaine
[Musique]
et député qui travaille sur le sujet ont
livré leur diagnostic rassurant mais il
estime que des menaces persistent dans
des secteurs sensibles comme celui des
transports du sport ou encore dans les
prisons mari la bat
ils sont une trentaine dans la police et
la gendarmerie
une dizaine dans l'administration
pénitentiaire et moins de 0,05 pour cent
dans l'armée à première vue les services
publics sont donc relativement préservée
des cas de suspicion de radicalisation
souvent grâce aux enquêtes
administrative menée préalablement au
recrutement de pas réagir à la
radicalisation dans ses services publics
serait non seulement j'allais dire à
amoindrir l'autorité de l'état mais
aussi faire courir des risques graves à
la sécurité de nos concitoyens car
plusieurs zones d'ombré subsistent et
notamment dans le secteur des transports
publics ou même dans le milieu carcéral
nous sommes d'une part inquiet de
l'imprécision concernant le nombre de
détenus de droit commun en voie de
radicalisation
je vous rappelle que des individus comme
chérif y ait 4 mohamed merah à médicaux
lib ali mehdi des mouches ou récemment
michael joe lo se sont radicalisés en
détention plus étonnant pour les députés
le prosélytisme dans les milieux
sportifs c'est pas évident parce que le
sport est avant tout un vecteur
d'intégration et pourtant il est d'abord
urgent notre avis de clarifier de
mesurer l'étendue de la radicalisation
dans ce secteur les domaines de la santé
de l'université sont aussi ciblés par le
rapport
en cause une politique de prévention de
détection et de signalisation de la
radicalisation peu développé est ce que
vous êtes rassurés par le diagnostic
fait dans ce rapport parlementaire est
ce que ce rapport était utile pour vous
le rapport était utile mini pas
rassurant j'entendais le reportage et on
parlait de relativement satisfaisant des
gens voient 2
c'est pas prêt si pour vous c'est pas
prêt si je veux dire il fallait faire ce
diagnostic il n'est pas rassurant il
faut donner plus de moyens pour
connaître la situation quand vous
embaucher quelqu'un j'ai été maire très
longtemps quand on embauche quelqu'un
pour accompagner les jeunes ou dans les
associations sportives ou pour toutes
sortes d'activités
il faut savoir qui on embauche il faut
pouvoir avoir plus d'informations donc
il faut que les élus soient mieux
associés et il faut que les textes
soient précisées pour j'allais dire
faire en sorte que si on s'aperçoit que
quelqu'un pose problème en puissance et
parer aux informations notamment dans
les fichiers est puisqu'il ya eu un
examen de mer qui demandait avoir accès
au fichier est pour vous pas responsable
par exemple tout ça est trop imprécis et
puis on revient toujours sur la question
vestimentaire de gens qui à un moment ou
un autre
puis on j'allais dire des tenues
vestimentaires qui ne sont pas adaptés
par rapport à la réglementation en
termes j'veux dire de laïcité vis-à-vis
de l'ensemble de tous ceux qui
fréquentent les services publics
donc il faut pouvoir se séparer de ces
jours-là donner plus de pouvoir aux
préfets mieux travailler avec les élus
locaux et précisé la réglementation et
la loi sur les zones non brin parce
qu'il y en a quand même notamment dans
les transports dans les prisons il faut
s'en inquiéter et comment on fait il
faut s'en inquiéter c'est pas nouveau 1
c'est un sujet tous les élus connaissent
ça je veux dire on voit très bien la
filtration qui correspond à un mouvement
dans la société
donc à partir de là on voit bien ce qui
s'est passé à grenoble vous avez des
femmes ont dit ce sont des mères de
famille tu parles
c'est une association qui est connue qui
est proche des frères musulmans et il ya
une espèce de volonté d'aller ont
précisé pour téléspectateurs de cette
opération coup de poing qui dimanche
deux femmes qui sont venues se baignant
bien là un burqini dans une piscine de
grenoble on peut pas sous la pression
commençait à avoir des ségrégations
communautaire dans le sport avoir la
même chose après demain dans l'école
avoir d'autres situations comme celle là
parce que on va vouloir nous imposer des
situations il faut que les élus puissent
rejet c'est compliqué en même temps
est-ce que vous pensez que les pouvoirs
publics sont suffisamment armé notamment
il faut des forces de renseignement il
faut beaucoup de renseignements pour
pouvoir suivre détecter même déjà
c'est qu'il ya assez de moyens pour
lutter contre ce phénomène assez parfois
indétectable sûrement non il c'est un
problème parce que ça coûte cher et ça
sera sûrement un des points qu'on va
aborder ce budget de l'état mais il ya
déjà quand même beaucoup d'informations
il faut peut-être trouver les moyens de
mieux les partager entre l'état et les
élus locaux pour savoir qui est qui est
ce que l'état y travaillent aujourd'hui
l'état il travaille il est obligé d'y
travailler
encore hier il ya eu des incidents pas
très loin de chez nous en tunisie deux
attentats c'est quoi une ou deux heures
d'avion la tunisie on parle des services
publics de la radicalisation des
services publics ce que l'état devrait
mieux surveiller ces recrutements au
départ l'état l'état et les
établissements publics vous parliez les
rangs sport la ratp la sncf on sait
qu'ils aiment beaucoup de recrutements
et organismes publics oui par exemple la
ratp
et tant mieux a beaucoup recruté dans
les cités notamment dans l'est parisien
simplement le revers de la médaille
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
de radicalisation après la publication
de ce rapport bruno retailleau qui
préside le groupe l'est républicain au
sénat appelé manuel macron à lever toute
ambiguïté sur la question de la laïcité
vous aussi oui il s'est surtout les
textes qu'il faut préciser je veux dire
à chaque fois on est dans la demi-mesure
alors regardez les affaires du burqa les
affaires je veux dire on fait des textes
mais qui sont extrêmement difficiles à
appliquer vous imaginez bien les
policiers ils ont autre chose à faire
que de courir ici ou là après des femmes
qui pourrissent et les taxes et pas
emmanuel macron qui est ambigu sur cette
question pour vous il est président de
la république donc il faut que son
gouvernement prenne j'allais dire des
textes à soumettre au parlement pour
préciser les textes en question à savoir
ce qu'on a le droit de faire ce qu'on
n'a pas le droit de faire il faut donner
les moyens aux élus qui embauchent et
puis aussi à l'état de savoir qui ils
embauchent à les autres sujets cette
semaine la cour des comptes a une
nouvelle fois tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
[Musique]
la cour des comptes a donc publié cette
semaine son traditionnel rapport sur
l'état des finances publiques et devant
les sénateurs didier migaud qui préside
l'institution a appelé le pays à sortir
de ses travers jérôme rhabiller comme
souvent didier migaud distribuer bons et
mauvais points dans le rapport annuel de
la cour des comptes les bons points sont
pour l'année 2018 avec une réduction du
déficit et une maîtrise de la dépense
publique mais les sages de la rue cambon
s'inquiètent pour l'avenir notamment à
cause des annonces faites durant la
crise des gilets jaunes et à la fin du
grand débat national des annonces
chiffrées à 10 7 milliards d'euros qu'il
faudra compenser qu'il est vraisemblable
que loi de programmation nouvelle sera
nécessaire et que le gouvernement
précise document davantage sa capacité à
observer respecter les nouveaux
objectifs qu'il s'est défilé qui sont
d'ailleurs moins ambitieux si le
gouvernement a été prompte à trouver des
impôts a baissé ou des baisses de
charges pour les entreprises les
économies sur la dépense publique sont
plus incertaines mais pour les élus de
la république en marche
l'objectif sera atteint toutes les lois
que nous votons vont aussi permettre
et bien cette réduction qualitative de
la dépense publique c'est à dire en
utilisant aussi une nouvelle technologie
donc il faut baisser les impôts parce
qu'il ya un trop plein fiscale dans ce
pays et maîtriser la dépense publique
moi je pense que avec la croissance qui
revient nous réussirons autre motif
d'inquiétude pour didier migaud
les taux d'intérêt historiquement bas et
qu'ils sont même devenus négatifs la
semaine dernière permettent une marge de
manoeuvre mais la situation ne sera pas
éternel et provoque le débat chez les
économistes comme chez les sénateurs ont
sans doute livre à une
une montée des taux d'intérêt mais on ne
sait pas dans quel délai et à quel
niveau
en tous les cas ce sera un impact direct
sur nos finances publiques mais vous
avez aussi une théorie qui se développe
par certains économistes qui est de dire
on a des taux d'intérêt bas il faut
aussi investir le gouvernement devrait
dévoiler des premières pistes
d'économies lors du débat d'orientation
budgétaire qui s'ouvrira le 11 juillet
au parlement avec marcel faut-il
s'inquiéter une certaine dérive des
finances publiques avec toutes ces les
annonces en cachette
vous êtes inquiet vous même c'est tout
ça est préoccupant mais c'est pas
nouveau ça fait des décennies qu'on fait
du déficit c'est plus facile qu'on
alimente la dette et ce gouvernement a
essayé de faire ce qu'ils pouvaient pour
j'allais dire revenir sur cette
situation on en parle à chaque élection
présidentielle et puis après il faut
gérer
là il ya un laisser-aller visible en
2005 la cour des comptes choix qui a été
fait assez mais c'est un choix c'est je
pense je pense que c'est un choix fut
qui est assumée pourquoi parce que gilet
jaune ont occasionné une situation grave
au mois de décembre dernier il a fallu
parer au plus pressé
on a lâché j'allais dire je les voter un
tout le monde assume pas ce que vient
plus met le feu au lac et donc on a voté
environ 12 à peut-être 13,14 milliards
de dépenses c'est pas budgétée on est
parvenu dans le budget et puis il ya eu
le grand débat et puis on a annoncé des
mesures
bon il y en a pour un gros 23 milliards
sur le quinquennat bon parce qu'une
partie des mesures pour après 2022 donc
on sait pas ce que ça deviendra baisse
les impôts c'est formidable on aurait un
dext la retraite des retraités
nous y sommes favorables après il faut
trouver des économies et le brun demande
elle échappe à la vérité vraie c'est que
les élections européennes bruxelles est
en train de se réorganiser et pendant ce
temps-là board y écouter ils n'ont pas
le temps de s'occuper de nous on va
laisser filer le déficit
1 parce que voilà et on va essayer de
trouver des économies alors mon collègue
dit oui il va falloir maîtriser
bon tout ça est formidable mais où
comment vous avez oui vous avez le
gouvernement va s'attaquer aux niches
fiscales est ce que ça c'est une bonne
chose il et quels bons parce que on est
dans un pays très paradoxal sur tout le
monde dit il faut faire c'est pas une
bonne idée de s'attaquer aux niches
fiscales par exemple pour réduire un peu
niches fiscales celui des augmentations
d'impôts parce que quand vous bénéficiez
d'une belle dune d'une réduction d'impôt
par une niche fiscale
si vous supprimez la niche ça veut dire
qu'on augmente votre impôt donc d'un
côté on baisse les impôts des classes
moyennes
et puis on va augmenter l'impôt des
entreprises par exemple on va dire avait
alors on va pénaliser l'emploi
donc chaque gouvernement est un
gouvernement à renoncer à tout objectif
de baisse des dépenses et du déficit je
pense qu'il y aura des mesures qui
seront cosmétique mais qui n'iront pas
au fond du sujet parce que c'est
extrêmement compliqué extrêmement
difficile et que je ne vois pas comment
on peut j'allais dire alimenté en
contrepartie les dépenses qui qui ont
été faites quoi on va parler dans
quelques instants de la loi climat
puisqu'elle est examiné à l'assemblée
durant l'audition de didier migaud les
sénateurs ont alerté sur la dette
écologique qui pourrait être plus
importante plus dangereuse que la dette
financière est ce que vous êtes d'accord
oui là encore il faut connaître
précisément les chiffres le débat n'a
pas encore eu lieu au sénat il aura lieu
à partir de la mi juillet mais là encore
on ne fallait même affiné à l'assemblée
vais donc on verra ce qui vous était à
l'assemblée définitivement et puis
surtout sont des dépenses nouvelles
aussi on vient de parler de la dette du
déficit mais sont des pensionnaires
alors sont des dépenses vertueuse il
faut les faire on voit bien qu'on est
dans une situation compliquée qui a des
mesures fortes à prendre il ya eu les
accords de paris sont assez peu
respectée au plan international tout le
monde voit bien qu'il faut faire quelque
chose ça va coûter de l'argent mais il
faut prendre les mesures définitivement
est-ce qu'on arrête les centrales
atomiques à la rue youri oui oui on en a
justement puisque coïncidence du
calendrier le projet de loi énergie
climat est arrivé ce mardi dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée nationale en
même temps que la canicule
[Musique]
le projet de loi fixe les nouveaux
objectifs du gouvernement en matière de
transition énergétique et de réduction
des émissions de co2 et les points
chauds de ce texte en 60 secondes avec
laszlo gelabert c'est la mesure
emblématique du texte celle qui annonce
la couleur
l'urgence écologique et climatique
décrété à l'article 1er pour 41 contre 7
l'article 1er est donc adopté dans son
sillage le gouvernement ambitionne de
réduire de 40 % la consommation
d'énergie fossile d'ici 2030 et la
neutralité carbone à l'horizon 2050
très décrié les centrales à charbon
seront fermées d'ici 2022
pour ce faire un plafond d'émissions de
co2 est instauré pour les installations
de production électrique à partir de
combustibles fossiles
quant aux salariés ils bénéficieront
d'un accompagnement spécifique sur le
dossier sensible des centrales
nucléaires la réduction à 50% de la part
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité française est prévue d'ici
à 2035 contre 2025 dans la loi de
transition énergétique voté lors du
quinquennat précédent
enfin ces derniers jours la question des
passoires thermiques
ces logements très mal isolé a fait
débat jusqu'au sein de la majorité
la barça est ce que pour vous ce texte
est assez ambitieux alors où les
français sont touchées par la canicule
où on voit les effets du dérèglement
climatique
oui simplement il faudrait y voir un peu
plus clair parce qu'on n'arrête pas de
fermer des centrales qui ne ferme pas
finalement on a vu les
valses-hésitations durant le quinquennat
précédent avec monsieur volant et madame
royal maintenant revient sur ces dates
je doute qu'on puisse à la fois ferme et
aussi rapidement des centrales atomiques
et atteindre la neutralité carbone en
2050 fermer les usines à charbon
c'est une bonne chose de fermer les
usines à charbon parce que ça pour le
coup c'est violent pour leur dernière
saisine ou alarmant de françois que ce
texte c'est beau sur le papier mais que
ce n'est pas crédible
j'attends j'attends des explications
parce que j'ai le sentiment que
c'est quelque chose qui s'annonce bien
on dit on ferme les centrales avant 2025
pour le charbon on va enfin fermer
certaines centrales atomiques et puis on
va avoir d'autres solutions alternatives
c'est là où j'aimerais bien être sûr que
ces solutions alternatives apporte à
notre pays ses besoins énergétiques au
cou nous l'avons aujourd'hui parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a la chance grâce à la
tomme d'avoir une énergie peu cher c'est
bien pour notre économie et c'est bien
aussi pour notre environnement
alors il faut qu edf se secoue un peu
parce que on voit flamanville que le br
c'est pas forcément un grand succès
alors hervé marseille un point du texte
qui fait qui fait débat c'est la
question des passoires énergétiques un
amendement avait été adopté en
commission
prévoyez une consignation sur la vente
de ces logements pour financer la
rénovation il a été retoquée au profit
d'un nouveau dispositif qui a été
présenté ce vendredi écouter le
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques au 1er janvier 2000 28 sera
indiquée donc dans toutes les publicités
acte de vente et les baux le non respect
de la conformité du bien à la suite de
quoi si sanction il doit y avoir et nous
nous proposons que nous en débattions en
2023 parce qu'en 2023
c'est le rendez vous que nous nous
sommes fixé collectivement en acceptant
cette loi programmatique où les
parlementaires seront amenés à
s'exprimer sur la trajectoire de la
politique énergétique d'une api c'est à
ce moment là parce que nous serons
milieu du chemin que nous pourrons
décider collectivement si on est au
rendez vous de la rénovation énergétique
si notre pays est au rendez vous de la
rénovation énergétique ou pas et s'il
n'y est pas nous déciderons
collectivement des sanctions qui doivent
s'y rattachent et voilà entre dit celui
qui est bien le rapporteur de ce texte
est ce que vous comprenez quelque chose
est reversée à ce nouveau dispositif
pour lutter contre les passoires
thermiques
oui passoires thermiques c'est bien
c'est là encore c'est un sujet qui est
pas nouveau pendant le grenelle de
l'environnement jean louis borloo et
prix déjà la mesure du
sujet edouard philippe en décembre 2018
et déjà annoncé des mesures qui ont été
rapidement démenties
les jours suivants par des mesures
beaucoup plus ambitieuse est ce que
cette action n'est pas un peu précipité
c'est cet amendement qui a été présenté
pour il est beau dit la démarche est
important et maintenant c'est le système
qui est compliqué quoi je dirais
reporter ça à 2033 je ne sais quand
c'est ça veut dire quoi pour vous c'est
il ya le temps de changer 14 mois de loi
d'ici là comme toujours de chez nous
donc je veux dire il faudrait savoir
clairement et de façon simple ce qu'on
peut ceux qui ont des maisons mal
isolées des appartements mazilu et sur
les gens qui ont peu de moyens 7
millions de ménages concerts voilà c'est
les mêmes à qui on demande de changer de
voiture parce qu'elle est polluante
c'est les mêmes qui ont dit il faut
aller au contrôle technique
ça donnait les gilet jaune on peut pas
toujours reporté sur le citoyen j'allais
vers des obligations que l'état devrait
davantage prendre en considération
morale et stigmatise pour vous ces
personnes qui vivent dans des loges
année stigmatise pas mais en même temps
les accompagne pas comme il faudrait
entre des femmes ont dit à voix tu repos
lui ta maison pollue tout ça ça va pas
il faut que tu changes tout ça et tu vas
le payer alors on lui dit ah jusqu'à
2030 trois longueurs donc c'est tout ça
n'est pas assez trop compliqué c'est pas
assez simple il faut y aller franchement
on met les moyens et on fait choses
simples aller à partir de lundi le
parlement est convoqué en session
extraordinaire
[Musique]
une session qui devrait durer jusqu'à la
fin du mois de juillet avec un programme
chargé et que nous détaille quentin
calmer la lettre a été envoyée la
semaine dernière le parlement et
convoquer à partir de lundi pour la
session extraordinaire d'été une session
qui devrait courir jusqu'à la fin du
mois de juillet au programme cette année
les textes en cours d'examen entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
au gré de la navette parlementaire ainsi
les députés examinent cette semaine le
texte sur la collectivité unique
d'alsace
déjà adopté par le sénat quand un autre
texte doit revenir à la chambre haute se
lit sur notre dame prévu en séance le 10
juillet on le sait il ya désaccord sur
la reconstruction de la cathédrale entre
l'assemblée et le sénat
d'autres textes majeurs pour le
gouvernement terminent leur parcours
législatif
le projet de loi bancaire sur la réforme
de l'école et celui sur la santé tous
les deux ont fait l'objet d'un accord en
commission mixte paritaire entre
sénateurs et députés
mais le suspense perdure sur deux autres
textes
les deux chambres du parlement
parviendront-elles à un accord sur le
projet de loi mobilité ou sur celui de
la fonction publique en fonction le
calendrier sera plus ou moins tendue
selon le ministre des relations avec le
parlement à l'idée que nous avions
c'était de terminer la navette de textes
importants je pense à la loi
d'orientation mobilité j'ai cité écoles
et santé & gas la loi fonction publique
qui est encore en examen au sénat cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale va
débuter le texte sur l'énergie et le
climat
et puis il viendra ensuite au sénat donc
c'est quand même des textes importants
qu'on essaiera de clôturer au mois de
juillet puis s'ils sont pas que le tir
au mois de juillet pour certains ils
reprendront au mois de septembre le
projet de loi sur le climat et l'énergie
qui sera examiné par le sénat à partir
du 16 juillet mais deux autres textes ou
réformes sont très attendus en parallèle
de la session parlementaire
c'est en effet en juillet que le projet
de loi sur la pma sera présenté en
conseil des ministres dans le même temps
jean paul delevoye devrait donner les
grandes lignes de la très attendue
réforme des retraites alors sur certains
textes comme l'école ou la santé des
textes importants sur lequel au départ
il pouvait y avoir quand même des
divisions entre les deux chambres on a
vu finalement une bonne entente et voilà
que les deux chambres réussissent à
s'entendre sur une version gris comme
vous interprétez 7
ce fait assez inédit trillard quand tout
le monde s'y met on peut aboutir ça a
été le cas je veux dire il ya une
volonté commune de trouver des solutions
qui n'est pas évident on l'a fait la
biodiversité avec tous les problèmes de
la chasse et dieu sait si au sénat c'est
un sujet important
on a réussi à trouver les voies de
passage avec des concessions de part et
d'autre du sénat et de l'assemblée
mais ça le gouvernement il ya du bon
dans les réformes macron oui bien sûr il
ya des bd des réformes qui sont votées
largement il y en a d'autres qui sont
plus discutés mais c'était la situation
depuis le début du quinquennat
alors parmi les grandes réformes à venir
dans les prochaines semaines la réforme
des retraites qui devrait être présentée
par jean paul delevoye dans les
prochains jo est ce que vous la voyez
d'un bon oeil cette réforme
bien sûr je veux dire si nous avions été
au gouvernement on aurait fait s'être
cette réforme
bon en plus c'est une réforme qui
reprend beaucoup des préoccupations que
les centristes ont toujours exprimé la
retraite par points
jean paul delevoye s'est entourée comme
il le fait toujours ses sons c'est son
style la plus grande concertation de la
plus grande consultation nous nous
suivrons ça avec beaucoup d'intérêt
j'espère que ça aboutira et les lois
bioéthiques la raison des lois
bioéthiques qui va arriver discussions
qui s'annoncent assez tendue est ce que
votre position sur ces lois vous êtes
assez favorable à ce qu'il y ait un
débat large ouvert je pense que ça se
présente verte et tu vas tu
oui bien sûr liberté de vote si on l'a
toujours fait pour tous les textes et je
pense que ce texte présente peut-être de
façon plus apaisée que d'autres par le
passé il ya une volonté là aussi de
discuter tranquillement parce que ce
sont des sujets graal est la part de
tous de la part de tous est un problème
de conscience qui peut se poser pour
certains ou certaines et donc je pense
que le débat doit être apaisés faut voir
les choses sérieusement je pense que le
gouvernement amène les choses sur la
table
également beaucoup de précautions et je
pense que rimbaud débat débat important
et là aussi je pense qu'on peut pouvoir
aboutir à quelque chose de peta est
étonnant mais au sénat bah parce que on
s'attend pas à ce que le sénat votait ce
genre de texte et je pense que nous
penser que le sénat pauvreté notamment
la bm a pourtant tenu un mot pour finir
sur la sphère benalla puisqu'elle est
elle est revenue dans l'actualité cette
semaine jeudi on a appris que le parquet
n'engagerait pas de poursuites pour faux
témoignage contre le directeur de
cabinet des manuels mâcon patrick
strzoda ni contre alexis kohler et le
général lavernhe c'est le bureau du
sénat qui avait transmis leur cas à la
justice pour faux témoignage devant
cette commission d'affaires sénatoriales
vous vous étiez contre la transmission
de ces dossiers est ce que finalement
c'est un revers pour le sénat dont la
justice a tranché c'est par un revers
pour autant nous nous avions voté contre
cette saisine du parquet avec mes
collègues centristes au bureau et la
justice quelque part donne raison à
notre analyse
nous n'avions pas trouvé les arguments
qui justifiait cette saisine tant mieux
la justice a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
lieu de continuer cette enquête et c'est
une bonne chose mais qu'est ce que vous
dites que le sénat a voulu en faire trop
qu'il a voulu faire un coup politique
moi je pense qu'il ya eu une démarche de
trop et la commission sénatoriale a bien
travaillé tout le monde l'a reconnu et
beaucoup de travail et de bon travail
qui a été fait par philippa et la
commission il ya peut-être une ou deux
choses qui n'étaient pas nécessaires et
est superfétatoire ça a été le cas quand
le parquet par d'atteinte à la
séparation des pouvoirs vous êtes
d'accord avec cela
non je pense que chacun a son rôle la
constitution donne à chacun une
responsabilité le le parlement a fait ce
qu'il devait faire
surtout au sénat et puis la justice est
là ses compétences alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya des moments où chacun essaie de
tirer un peu plus sa compétence
un autre sujet plus grave c'est marion
maréchal-le pen je pense que il ya là
une faille qui a tendance à s'agrandir
et pour l'avenir on y sera très vigilant
mais il faut pas parler des
parlementaires notamment sont allés
dîner avec elle ils sont allés dîner
avec elle il faudrait pas que ça
devienne une habitude et que ça devienne
une démarche politique merci ce sera le
mot de la fin revint à marseille merci
d'avoir été notre invité merci hervé
marseille merci katia on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]